Just
kidding.
Wait, oh.
Did I?
Ah!
Spooky!
Who was that?
I actually had to possess somebody today for today's craft, so uh, enjoy!
Ah!
For today's craft, um, uh, sorry.
The lighting makes my sleeves look not white, but please be assured that they are white.
Or maybe they're just dirty.
I need to wash my jacket.
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Looks great to me.
Uh-oh.
Are you learning your colorblind today?
I am learning your colorblind today!
Senor, thank you so much for the video that you did!
Thank you!
Well guys, now I'm nervous.
I don't know why.
Cute witch.
I'm a witch.
Today!
Today, we are...
Making puppets!
And I needed some hands to make the puppets.
So I possessed somebody.
And this is them.
Voodoo dolls?
No, no, no.
No, just...
Well, okay.
They're just puppets.
But isn't that kind of spooky too?
if it's like, okay, being a puppet is kind of terrifying too, no?
Oh, the wind.
So, oh, I have something for you guys.
Welcome to the made cafe.
I baked you.
Well, actually, I accidentally left it in the oven for too long, I forgot about it.
I made you a cookie.
I have three.
Would you like to eat my cookie?
You love those?
Vito!
These are my favorite!
So...
Dozo?
Oh, that was so yummy, Vito.
Your cooking is delicious.
That's the bestest ever.
Or, wait.
Oh, Vito!
That was the best thing I've ever tasted!
How did you come up with such a brilliant recipe?
You're like...
A wizard!
Ah!
Stop it.
It was simple.
And look at this design?
How could she- how did she do it?
How did she do it?
Thank you guys, thank you!
Also, wait, I'm so sorry.
Oh my gosh, I missed a...
Aka.
No, well thank you!
The human of today has cute nails.
No, the human of today might have painted them just for this stream
So I'm not used to having Human nails so I possessed and then I painted so they might don't look so much they might be a little a little messy But I can do the Ariana Grande Aha,
look how my hand is in my oversized sweater.
Oh, you want to see how small my wrist is?
It's so, oh, my tiny wrist is so small in this oversized jacket.
I might be the tiniest person ever.
What do you mean, noodle eyes?
What?
Okay.
Oh, let me eat my cookies.
Hold on.
Look how cute these...
I almost called them blankets.
What are these called?
Napkins.
Look how cute they are.
Oh, I'm getting crumbs on my desk already.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Don't look.
Look how cute these are, though.
And they have like little fringe at the bottom.
For some reason.
It's kind of like a dress.
Actually, what happens if I pull it apart?
Oh!
What?
It's my birthday, please, homie!
Carbon!
Oh my gosh!
I split them into two!
Wait, this is like a whole pack, though.
Maybe I have too many now.
Wait, what happens if I split this guy into two?
Surely it...
They can't be that thin.
Oh, okay, wait.
Oh, wait.
Seriously?
Wait.
Huh?
No, I think it has to...
It doesn't unfold?
Goes to mitosis.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Like so.
Oh,
wow!
Is this how wisps are born?
Maybe.
Oh, wait, it's so cute, actually.
Wait, it's actually so cute.
Sorry, this one had a lobotomy.
That's you.
Baby!
Okay, cookie time.
Cookie time, because I totally didn't stall enough for this stream.
But I also left them in for too long, and so they're a little crunchy instead of...
Instead of chewy.
So I'm kind of sad.
I had one already.
Okay, itadakimasu.
Okay, bye-bye.
Whoa.
Yep, yep, thank you so much for the time, thank you, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you, guys, thank you.
So I'm making hand puppets today.
like so sorry my this finger is like double jointed so it can't bend properly um but yeah so oh i have no movement but i will move but mostly i have a live show And this is gonna be showing me who will pass it.
Wait, where is the...
Wait, so...
I thought...
I don't know how long it will take to make a puppet.
So I chose a couple people to make it.
And I thought maybe I'll do sloppy sisters.
And like one more person.
And maybe me?
but at the same time
one my store did not have so many fabric colors so so we're gonna do our best they're gonna be Halloween themed so I have yeah five and then I chose each every person to have a costume.
And so...
Oh wait, where's my fabric?
I have a bunch of felt and it will turn into people.
Happy...
Woo!
Okay.
See how I did...
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Let me move the cookies.
Oh.
You guys enjoy?
Actually, only one was enough, I think, for me.
I had two.
Don't worry about it.
Stop!
Oh my god!
tell you guys, I have a lyric video they sent me that I can that I can post.
Oh wait, I'll show you guys a little preview.
QQ-Shah.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me pause.
Pause, pause, pause, pause.
I'll show you.
I will post.
I will post this.
What's my next day off?
Sunday?
Yes.
Yeah?
gun really i got it because it's pink i mean no it's not sorry
ignore that my
desk too much because it's a gift okay
okay i gotta make sure i press i click the right spoil anything okay um okay okay
okay okay video no don't i'm gonna i'm gonna resize Oh,
it won't let me size it.
Unless I go to it.
Okay, hold on.
Stop making fun of me.
Okay, sorry.
It might be kind of loud at first.
I'll just mute it.
I'll mute it.
Mute, mute, mute.
Okay.
And then I'll start it over.
Oh, it's so big.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
Look, they did this.
Toei did this for me.
They're so nice.
They did this for me.
Wait, can I hear?
Oh, I can't hear it.
Oh.
Wait.
Like so.
Yeah.
Yeah, so everybody who was wanting
the lyrics.
Yeah.
Look how cute it is!
Ah!
I forgot
to drink!
I was so flustered getting the glue sticks.
So yeah, there you go.
Oh yeah.
There we go.
Yay!
Okay, my sleeve is dry.
I'm so sorry.
That's so embarrassing.
Now you guys know of when I say I'm crying.
I'm literally crying.
Oh, what's on them nails, girl?
Do you want me to go get the polish when I...
When I get a drink?
Same polish?
Say hey!
Oh my gosh!
I feel like I haven't seen you in forever.
Okay, I'll get my drink and then we start.
Because I gotta trace...
No, I gotta trace my hand for the...
puppet i have no idea what i'm doing you guys jay thank you so much for the thank you to thank you show you my mouse here it is you know it's uh logitech mx anywhere 3s okay uh i have you okay wait where did i put my cup
Where did I put it?
Now I actually don't know.
Nice pink mouse.
Marco, thank you so much.
Thank you for the gift.
It's so amazing.
Thank you.
20 gift.
Ah.
Where did I put it?
I thought I had it, though.
Hmm?
Okay.
Anyway.
I go get it.
one second hold on one second I'll write a message a dying message but I don't want to read it too big in case I need the the fabric you know
there we go
if it bled through no I think it'll be okay
Fucking...
One second, one second, one second, one second, one second, one second.
Okay.
Today, uh, this is my nail polish, by the way.
SC.
I don't remember where I got this, when I got this, but it's flavor eternal optimist.
You can't read it.
One four four.
Eternal optimist.
SC nail polish.
Okay.
Let me cut this.
I'm getting cat hair everywhere too.
Watch how smooth this is gonna be.
Oh, I missed a spot.
That's okay.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh, and my drink?
I don't know if you can see my...
Oh, you can't see my mug!
It's ghost!
Isn't it so cute?
This is one of my favorite mugs.
Little ghosts.
Okay.
All right.
So, I'm gonna start with my first...
Wait.
Wait, I had this idea.
Should I...
What if...
Okay, what if...
I was gonna tell you guys who I'm working on, But what if instead I start working on somebody and then you guess who I'm working on?
It was my birthday on the 14th, but I fell in a river.
What topic?
Hey!
Keep it a secret.
I think you guys might know the first one, though.
Maybe.
Wait, actually...
Oh, no, these are still fabric scissors, so I'll use them.
Okay, all right, let's get our first victim then.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to trace my hand on this, and then that will be our base.
Do I know what I'm doing?
No.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
But we're going to try anyway.
Wait if I could do half...
Oh!
I wish I could move my keyboard but actually it's not it's like plugged in it's not Bluetooth or anything so I think I could do it there's enough room right wait is it fully folded enough hmm I
pull up my sleeve okay We're gonna make it wide.
I'm scared!
Wait.
Shouldn't it be in the shape of the person?
Am I doing this right?
Whatever.
Wait.
Wait, my process is... I'm questioning everything right now.
Wait, I don't know what I'm doing.
It's staying the desk.
Don't worry, don't worry.
plus oh my gosh you guys i got a koharu desk mat and i've been waiting on it for like a long time and it happened the shipping happened right when like the tariff started so i don't think i'm ever gonna see her again i think like she got lost in the in the sauce of like all the stuff that was happening and so i think she's gone for good I'm so sad.
I'm so, so sad.
Hey, Kohalu.
It's a little hanging off, but I think it's okay.
Okay, you know what?
Trust the process.
Okay, guys.
Trust it.
Sorry, I only have like four songs.
Oh, wait.
Is this too much?
Okay, wait.
Trust the process.
process.
I have to have enough room for my hand to go through, right?
This is our first person!
Now I cut them out.
And then I glue it.
And then I glue it together.
Okay?
I'm gonna cut a little extra, like...
A little extra...
Maybe a little more.
I can't hurry.
off okay
uh scissors 61 oh okay
i can't do this and sing at the same time i can't do this and sing at the same time oh gosh
a trick and a treat for chat if you're in a place that thinks why i don't want to read that i don't i don't want to read that
do you see it do you see it right guys
don't worry this mat is very old and has actually it has like stains here too and stuff don't worry about it don't worry about it i'm not gonna cry
I'm just kidding.
What color are the scissors?
Blue!
Oh.
Because, you know, sometimes I eat ramen.
Um, on my desk.
Wait, is it?
Maybe I should have.
No, it's fine.
I was going to say maybe I should have pinned it.
But I don't think I have any pins left.
I think I got rid of all.
Oh gosh, okay.
I'm trying to make it not slip around anymore.
Uh-oh.
That's fine.
Oh, uh-oh.
Wait.
I think I just didn't fold it correctly.
I don't think it slipped or anything.
I think it just didn't fold it right.
Oh,
I forgot to plug in.
That was definitely one of the super chats of all time.
Don't repeat it.
Stokey board.
How did you know?
Open bit?
No!
Wait, hold on.
Let me plug in my...
I forgot to plug in the hot glue gun.
Don't...
Not for consumption.
consumption one second it's under my desk i just gotta get under here
i hit my head that's why i yelled okay this needs to stand up so that it doesn't okay all right now we glue it together i can't believe i did that i can't believe i literally ate my own foot you guys were like don't get it on your desk you're gonna get it on your desk and i said no i'm not guys No,
I did it right there.
That's crazy.
You literally, yeah, I hit my foot.
It's all bloody right now.
I'll show you.
It's red and bloody.
Ah,
it burns!
Okay, wait, let me look at Doki now.
Okay, well, you guys don't know what I'm making Doki.
Wait, actually, I just realized.
I just realized something.
Hold on.
Oh, thank goodness they fit.
Oh, okay, okay.
I was worried.
But
it kind of looks like a ghost.
right now no okay um you guys then will have to guess what costume what halloween what her halloween costume is okay um let's see uh okay let's start with her hair right so i have some i think as soon as i brought this out you guys would probably know who it is so no you can't guess yet you can't guess yet okay oh gosh the sound is so much easier in my brain.
I was like, oh, I'll just cut out her hair.
You know what?
I will do that.
In fact, I will just cut out her hair.
Okay.
Alright.
We're going to do the front and the back.
Okay.
I'm just going to outline it as I see it on her reference photo, and then I'll cut that and glue it on her head.
Okay, okay.
Good, good, good.
Oh, wait, I need to glue these together.
I need to glue this.
Okay, hold on.
I need to probably make this inside out, right?
This still works, right?
Yeah, yeah, okay, good.
I'm testing if I can get in here.
Okay.
Oh no, guys!
Wait.
It's okay.
I'll just have...
I'll just leave one bigger flat.
How much of this is you winging it?
Like, the whole thing.
That's flat and white.
Is she beat down?
No!
Doki is also flat.
What are you talking about?
Okay, wait.
We're going to wing the whole thing.
thing.
We're doing it live, folks.
We're doing it live.
Okay, it's not hot enough.
Okay, it is on.
Oh, it wasn't in.
This wasn't in.
Okay.
It wasn't getting, it wasn't glue.
That's why.
It wasn't melting, I mean.
It's too big.
Stop it right here.
I have a gun and I will shoot if you keep making fun of me, I will shoot.
You didn't hear that YouTube.
It's a glue gun.
It's a glue gun?
Ouch.
Oh, oh, oh, here it comes.
Maybe I should have done sockpucket puppets, not pockets, sorry.
What's wrong with me?
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
You want the secret with hot glue is you gotta get it and then glue it.
Mint with a gun doesn't exist.
I have no trigger discipline either!
Oh, I need another stick.
already okay glad I got the big pack okay plus one to Ducky's compilation no okay
I sure hope I could get my hand in here why didn't anybody you guys how many people are here and none of you stopped to be you're all complicit but but but but but if Ducky is as bad it's fine We can, we'll fix everybody else.
Okay, hold on.
Let me just try and get my hand in here.
Yes!
It works.
Oh my gosh, this is gonna be so good.
This is gonna be so good.
Time for hair!
Okay.
I'm measuring.
Whatever.
We wing it.
Ah!
I dropped my pen.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh my gosh, we are so back.
We are so back.
Trust the process!
The keyboard and desk mat colorway goes crazy.
This?
I know.
You seemed confident at first.
Why'd we stop that?
I don't know.
Okay, I'm just gonna do like a small chunk of her.
Okay, I'm gonna try and not make it too wide.
Actually!
That kind of fits.
her costume maybe
you don't need the gun your cuteness has killed me like 50 times already
wait did you see that
alright so the Doki has like air vents kind of similar to mine which are currently covered and I'm suffocating but that's okay
trust the process trust the process The process!
Trust the process.
Uh-oh, I think I- I'm too far over.
Who else needs yellow?
Hold on, I'm checking my list.
I'm checking it twice.
Only- Doki.
Redu!
Okay, these are her hair vents.
Okay, trust the process.
We'll just do one single in the middle.
Trust the process.
This is going to look so stinking cute and good.
Oops, I messed up.
That's fine.
It's just dope.
She's our first one.
It's kind of hard to draw this.
Oh, wait.
Why does she look like Joey Wheeler or something?
I gotta get up and pace around the house about this for like five minutes.
Why?
Stop!
Don't leave!
Where's my scissors?
Oh.
Okay.
Trust?
No, process.
Okay.
I can't unsee it.
What if I made it too small?
No, it's not possible.
It's not possible.
Don't even bring that up.
Why would you bring...
Why would you bring that up?
Okay.
Why am I cute?
Why is this song always...
come on when i start cutting it's my birthday sorry this is a heart it's a heart happy birthday oh sorry i'm cutting my mic on accident
what i can do is i can fix this
you are q and wiggly today i'm always like this actually this is this is how i always am actually maybe but when i'm when i am when i when i when i uh when i possess i get i i'm not used to human features.
So it's kind of fun.
Mm-hmm.
Cute.
Happy.
Okay, this part's hard.
Wait, I'm just gonna, what am I doing?
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo.
Okay.
I think I messed it up.
I think I messed it up, but that's okay.
Hmm.
I figured because my song is a little spooky, I could use it as Halloween BJM.
Is that okay?
I checked your merch store.
Oh, I can't find it.
New merch.
I posted a community post about it.
So, if you're looking for a direct link to it, you can go to the community post on YouTube.
Thanks for asking.
I hope this isn't too small.
I'm really scared, you guys.
You guys, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
What if it's too small for her head?
You think I made it all right?
We're winging it?
We're winging it.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
Moment of truth in coming.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna be able to make everybody.
We'll see.
I'm kind of slow.
All right, moment of truth!
Okay, thanks!
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the super chats I really, really appreciate.
Thank you too, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, here we go.
She dropped an eye.
Okay, we'll get the full effect.
Okay, ready?
Ready for the hair?
I'm
scared.
I might be a genius.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I might be a genius.
And then this can be like her...
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
This piece.
Right here.
Wait, I'll cut it nicer.
She has one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She does.
Oh, this part.
Right there.
Why did I cut it so small?
Oh, well, I need to cut it much smaller anyway.
It's fine, it's fine.
Like so.
Sorry.
Hi!
Whoa, thank you so much for the- The Minto is process we trust.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's glue this down.
this part.
The Ahogi first.
Sorry, the lighting is kind of strange with Doki.
Okay.
That should be good.
Oh, out!
Out, out, out, out.
Uncanny resemblance.
I know!
Oh, my gosh.
Totally love the mixed part of the song.
But there are parts I can't make out.
What does it say?
It says... In English or Japanese?
Like, hold on actually let me get the lyrics up
let me let me glue let me glue let me glue I'm getting ahead wait I think I should glue her eyes down first
she's cross-eyed a little bit but that's okay that's like so her oh oh sorry the body is hot just like you baby
okay that was late the finger gun okay anyway okay she's getting strings in her eyes but i can fix her
okay hold on there's like so much string on here oops oopsie okay oh wait i just accidentally pushed her eyeball in hold on oh wait i can fix her oh
i fixed it okay We're okay, we're okay.
All right.
But she still got a little bit of string on her.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Ha, hair.
Her hair.
Wait.
Okay.
Like so.
Okay, perfect.
Perfect.
I don't know where to glue.
I guess everywhere.
I just gotta make sure it doesn't...
Oh gosh.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Did I get it?
I think so.
Okay.
Alright.
I might be a genius for real.
Wait, let me go back to...
Okay.
But there's still more hair.
There's still more hair.
That we need to take care of.
So...
Okay.
But, wait, I can, I can, I can, uh, I can, uh, draw her face.
Yeah, her costume.
Alright,
you guys ready?
You probably will guess what she is after I do this.
She's Doki the Werecat!
Don't kitty!
Actually, so now we need to make kitty ears.
She's donky the wear cat!
So, like, this size?
Should be good.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, you know what?
I can wing it.
Like so?
Wait, hold on.
We're going to make them ultra-detailed.
I'm a perfectionist.
Look at that fluff tuft.
Look at that.
Oh!
Yeah.
Wait.
I guess I just have to glue it to the back.
Yes.
Okay.
I glue it to the back.
Plenty of glue
Plenty of glue Let's pick up some merch Thanks for that Thank you Thank you so much for ordering Thank you Thank you Is that just felt fabric?
It is
Okay Okay Okay Okay She has a hoagie Oh my goodness Thank you guys I can hear Doki wear cat saying downward dog.
I'm in Japan right now!
I'm going to Akihabara today.
Any suggestions on where to go for cool stuff?
Thank you in advance.
What kind of cool stuff?
Doki no Ushimaki.
We'll do her Ahogi.
She has two of them, so...
I really want to get through the ones that I bought all this stuff for today, but even though Then I had to cut somebody out because I was like, there's no way.
I think I was a little ambitious.
I was like, yeah, let's go.
I could do everybody in the world.
Let's go.
I thought I was a little ambitious.
I love crafty minnow.
Thank you.
There we go.
Is that a seal?
No, it's Doki.
It's Doki bird.
This one.
I wish I had, I intended originally to have a little bit of the, what's it called, the head lobotomized so that I could stick things in there.
But, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this one's gonna burn.
This one's gonna burn my newly discovered flesh today.
All right, here I go.
Burning for you, baby.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, that hurt way more than I thought.
Humans are so fragile.
Looks just like her.
Oh wait.
This is- this will help, this will help, this will help.
This will help.
There you go!
There you go.
Stop saying Joey Wheeler.
Because I know you're right.
You're making me feel bad.
I'm making the other Ahoy Garen now.
I don't have to do maybe she can be naked on the back from the front all you need to see is from the front anyway right oh I should have glued both at the same time oh wait it's still it's wait it's still I love arts and crafts during Halloween time you guys it's why I always tend to do Halloween arts and crafts stuff I don't know it always reminds me of just like I don't know being a kid I thought Doki was streaming when did this become a collab wait
wow wait oh synapse thank you so much for the Akasupa yeah
perfect Okay, now she looks like she's giving me sass right now.
Okay, now we need to do the back of her hair, which I guess we don't have to make her bald, but she's definitely going to be naked on her back, probably.
We'll probably do like a kind of a big swoopy here, which I could probably reuse this, maybe.
Nah, that's fine.
Like I said, I don't need any more yellow.
Let's clean up a little bit.
All trash goes on the plate.
Oh!
Her other ear!
Oh my gosh.
I almost left her with just one ear.
Oh.
Why did I just wing it?
I'm getting marker on me!
Is this the same?
size roughly oh guys wow i'm so good she's too she's too good she's too good how does she do it
how does she do it how does she do it
Okay, okay, okay, okay, nice, okay.
Love your rendition of Snaking Up on Mouse?
Why were the subtitles like that?
Why?
They were so goofy!
too good okay
to be fair triangles on your ghost headpiece are kind of the same true okay now let's wing it okay so I said it was gonna be like a flippy okay it's got to be flippy and then oh my gosh um gift hire me for your food right now I have a hidden talent that must be recognized guys I'm opening up I'm opening up what's the words pre-order no commissions today for plushies okay
Uh, okay.
I want it really like that, you know?
Oh, I went too far, I think.
Wait.
Did I go far enough?
We'll figure it out.
We'll find out.
Okay.
We'll figure it out.
I'll give it a little extra room.
I think.
I think...
I think it's okay.
I think it's fine.
Oh gosh.
One of my favorite parts about the lyrics of the song...
Is...
There's one...
So the first part is...
Saying I will cast like a magic spell on you.
And then it says I will kill you myself.
And the...
Did we did?
Flushy!
Yeah!
How dare you go to the...
kickabout other girls in front of me um please read the rules no mentioning other vtubers unless i mention them first thank you um what was i saying oh and so it says i'll cast a magic spell on you and then it says i will kill you but then the second part is saying i will i will um cast a curse on you and it says i will make you happy so it's kind of like subverting you know because you're like,
oh, magic spell!
And then it's, I'll kill you.
And then it's like, oh, you'll make me happy.
It's a curse.
Okay, this part's a little annoying.
I'm not going to lie.
Doki, stop.
Go bald.
Go bald, Doki bird.
Go bald right now.
Go bald, I dare you.
I dare you right now.
Go bald.
Maybe I'll just make a couple of them.
Or...
Help, help.
Well, it's only been an hour, but I'm still pretty far from completing Doki.
We'll see how...
Maybe I can get like...
Two.
Three.
Done.
You said Doki naked on the back, killed 100 jikus.
Thank you for using my art as a thumbnail!
Thank you!
It's so cute art!
Thank you so much!
Froegert.
What's Froegert?
Thank you for threatening my life.
At least three times this stream.
Yeah, this one's for you, Grupple.
My Fumo idea is a sloppy sister's collection.
That would be fun.
I also wanted to do, like, Phoebe and Vicky.
But I was like, wait, I can't do Vicky.
You guys kind of know what she looks like, but not enough where I feel like I can make a plushie of her.
without giving away too many things, you know, so...
Okay.
Ugh.
Oh, it's not so bad!
But you can't see it because...
You can't see her...
Maybe when I, like, put my hands down, you'll see it.
You know?
Wait, actually, it's way too small.
Wait, I can fix it.
I can fix it.
Am I allowed to mention the fabulous and amazing Vithubr...
Vithubr and Tobe on this stream?
Where?
Where is she?
That's me looking around single action safety lock scissors.
Okay.
How much thicker does this need to be?
Okay, like here.
I had it here.
It needs to be like here.
We're good.
Everything's okay.
We can fix.
We...
I'm basically... I'm possessing somebody.
I'm possessing a human.
I'm basically alive right now.
Which means I can say I live and I adapt.
Pretty much.
Is that the saying?
Or is there a saying like that?
Is there a saying... Okay, I messed up her hair a little bit.
She's got a bad haircut right there.
But, um... Wait, I could just flip it around but then you see oh wait she has a bald spot there too okay wait she has a couple bald spots oh no it has to be the side she has a couple bald spots but you know don't bring it up she's very self-conscious about it oh it's actually it works though no i think it works It's fine,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
This is...
shading.
And stuff.
You know?
It's like the shading of her hair or something.
Bolding Doki.
Yeah, don't tell her.
Don't tell her.
Oh, that's just...
The person you possessed has such cute hands.
Oh my gosh, you think so?
You think so?
You think they're cute?
Okay!
Very good.
Now let's make...
Um...
Well, it's wear...
Okay.
It's wear, don't kiddies.
So, here's the vision.
Wait, but I bought that color for her shirt.
What was I thinking?
for her shirt but it's fine it's fine um hair jacket hair because she's all because she's a furry
okay good i'm glad we're on the same page okay i'm glad we're on the same page Wait!
Oh my gosh, what if I do this?
See how it's, like, kind of fuzzy?
I'm innovating right now.
I'm innovating?
Tease it out!
Wait, is this enough?
Yeah, I think because then we can have the jacket go like this.
Let me cut it first.
And I'm even...
Look at me reusing my pieces.
You guys are gonna get sick of this song.
Okay,
this is hard work, you guys.
How can I fuzz her out faster?
Do you guys want to see my...
My...
Um...
Hold on.
Look at how cute this is.
This is my bag of...
throat stuff.
So...
We have some...
Uh...
No doame.
What is it?
What's that?
Uh...
What is it called?
Pop drops!
Thank you.
Now we have my favorite, my super o susume, my super recommendation.
Mintia plus voice.
They taste delicious.
They're lemon ginger.
They're good.
Okay, this is why they're...
This is why they're the best.
One, they're good for your throat.
Two, it has ginger in it.
So, when I...
When I've...
Several times people have been like, Oh, I...
I...
I'm feeling kind of like car sick or something.
I'll give them this because the ginger will help them from stopping nauseous.
It's so good.
Would you say, Mimi?
I'll never forget you saving me at Off-Kai with those.
They're so, so delicious.
These are my super dao susume.
Mintia voice.
And then, of course, another big recommendation.
Da-da.
The pei pakko.
Koa.
And then I have another.
one and then I have another one and then I have this one is just candy and then I have a throat coat this one I also like the throat coat I know I've tried the throat coat tea and it's kind of like in but this is the throat coat cough drop is really good this is my bag but this one is just
Regular candy, yeah.
Everything else?
Stuff it in here.
Yeah, isn't it so cute?
It's my bag of throat stuff.
I especially take it when I'm traveling.
And so if I'm recording at a studio or something, I have everything I need in here.
Oh yeah.
We were fuzzing her out.
Maybe if I, like, scratch her.
Use the edge of the scissors and scrape it across the fabric.
I'm scared.
I'm kind of scared.
These are really, these are fabric scissors, so they're very sharp.
I only use them for, like, when I'm, I used to make cosplay a little bit.
And...
Oh, yeah, that is helping.
That is helping.
I don't know if you guys can tell, though.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna...
Snip.
Do you have any Velcro?
Yes!
Yes, I do!
Oh my gosh, wait, I have it right here!
Because I had like a cable organizer.
Oh wait, I don't think it'll work.
Oh yes!
It does!
Good idea, good idea!
Oh yeah!
Could I borrow your scissors for...
Oh no!
No!
Wait, I don't know.
want to work at the i don't want to work for the scotland yard i don't want to be there oh i forgot i got a drink oh no my drink has fuzz in it now
i'm gonna give up making it hairy because you guys can't even oh you can't totally tell when i hold it up close it looks like crazy it looks like albert einstein
what is that it looks like it's
i thought you kept your candy elsewhere
Okay.
Alright, this is good enough.
Alright, so we do this and then we make her jacket.
And then...
Do-kitty should be done.
Where do-kitty should...
Oh!
What's happening?
I think...
I think it glued a little.
We're okay.
Alright, that should be enough.
Yes.
This song is so cute, what's it called?
It's called Spooky Pokey.
Spooky Pokey.
Okay, jacket time.
Wait, hold on, I got some string on me.
It feels like, it feels like, what's it called?
Um...
What's it called?
Oh, Spiderweb, you know?
Okay.
Let me get my black.
Oh, I also, I also got like, what's it called too?
I don't know if I'll ever need them.
I got cotton, the...
Not cotton balls.
The...
Pompoms.
I want to know how I can I use it, I wonder.
Wait a second, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
What if it's like little blush?
Wait!
Wait, it's kind of so cute.
Hold on, I'm trying to find another pink one.
Trying to find another pink one.
Oh, there we go.
It's so cute!
Wait, and then I got some, some of these, uh, these, these bad boys.
What do you call these?
These pipes, but I don't know what to use them for yet.
I just have them.
I went, I went to the total craft store and I said, your crafts.
Pipe cleaners!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Maybe we'll save this for last.
This will be the grand finale.
Okay.
Let's make a jacket.
How?
How do I do that?
Oh, I'm kidding.
I keep giving myself more room.
There we go.
Cats need collars, don't they?
It kind of looks like she has a giant goatee right now.
Like, she kind of looks like Guy Fieri.
They're also decently good for cleaning reusable straws.
No way, really.
For you, then welcome to Mephushab the Anchor.
Okay, how do I do this?
Oh no, she's starting to look like Dracula.
Furry Dracula.
What kind of keyboard do you use?
I love how it sounds.
Oh gosh.
Every now and then somebody asks me about this, but I...
I don't remember.
I said it like one time on a membership stream.
Okay.
calmo if you check the membership stream where i am typing you'll you'll you'll find it where i i think i even put it in the description wait i could just check that if i put it in the description i'm not saying you should draw a butt crack on the back like here wow she looks really naked suddenly i feel like i need to sense Okay,
hold on.
One second, one second, one second.
Hold on.
Live.
Okay, hold on.
Can I org us by...
No.
Wait, visibility.
Visibility?
Would that be members?
Yes, okay.
Apply.
Okay.
Huh?
Wait, where was it?
Was it this Membouz test stream?
You're upstream!
Now, what color are the scissors?
Oh, this was from an hour ago.
Stop!
Mako's K99!
Yeah!
M-M-Ko's K99 keyboard.
Doki's iconic dumpy.
Yeah, that she totally, totally had.
Yeah.
Wait, where did I do this stream, though?
Where did I do this one?
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
I didn't ride it.
I'm the worst.
But that's the one.
Where did it go?
Hold on.
You're pretty good.
I can't find it.
Oh, wait.
I found it.
I'm gonna put it in the description.
Maybe I tagged it or pinned it.
Okay, anyway, sorry, I'm getting all distracted.
Okay, okay, jacket time.
Jacket time.
She looks like a vampire!
Oh no!
It's...
I know what you are.
Say it.
We could also put like... we could put the blue underneath That I have that I got for her I could just do that
Spider monkey hold on spider monkey.
Oh, I almost just cut my fingers off Um, okay, let's do this I'll cut a straight line.
That wasn't bad!
It's a little crooked.
It's mostly straight!
Alright, so this will be for the bottom of her jacket.
Like this.
And also her sleeves.
Do you have a beauty mark?
No, I have...
I have Sharpie.
I have Sharpie on my head.
But I have a couple on my booty.
Okay, so I'm trying to get like the shape now.
So if I do it like this, maybe.
Okay, if I glue it like this.
I'm doing the out Like this maybe Okay, I know it's black And the felt is black too But it might show up
This is the one time we won't wing it It does show up Lucky eyes, okay Alright
We want to see them to make sure See what?
My booty I have a reference sheet Yosei I see it right there.
I promise you, they're there on my reference sheet.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm very serious about this craft.
Can you guys tell?
I think so far it's coming out pretty good.
What do you guys think?
Okay.
Now, I'm gonna cut over here.
Like that.
Okay.
Then...
It's easier to cut.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm scared!
What if I glue it now?
You know?
Wait.
Well...
Nah, it's okay.
Alright.
I cut.
I can kind of see it.
Wait, I can't see it.
Maybe.
Uh-oh.
Yes?
Wait.
I think it's here.
I think I see.
Oops.
Whatever.
Don't worry about it.
She's... she's...
We're do-kitty, so it can be a little frayed, you know?
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay!
The vision is visioning!
I know, I know!
Ah!
Okay, and then a little on...
Okay, let's glue this first.
Wait.
Yeah, because this part will need to be on top here.
Okay.
Let's glue, let's glue, let's glue...
This glue gun is...
Could be better.
Oh gosh.
Get burnt.
Okay.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed!
Fits for fur?
Okay.
Alright, now we do this part.
I'm a bit of a perfectionist, which is why it's hard for me to do some of these kinds of streams, you know?
Because I'm like, it's gotta look good!
Even when it doesn't look good!
Uh oh, wait, did I just mess that up?
Perfect.
Ish.
Close enough.
Okay.
It's coming together, baby!
She's coming together.
What do you guys think?
Her chest is a little open, but it's okay, probably.
The process is processing.
I want more space.
Okay, I'm going to get rid of my keyboard.
I'm sorry, everybody.
I'm going to get rid of my keyboard.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Alright, now we have...
Oh my gosh.
I have all this space.
Ugh.
Okay.
Look at here.
No, well thank you so much for the little toy!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Looks like you buffed Doki's chest.
No, it's hair!
Oh, oops.
That's my webcam.
There we go.
Okay.
Now...
We do the next part.
Which is...
Check it out!
Thank you so much for the fight!
Get it!
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay, I have to be careful here too.
We want it the same length, so...
About here, maybe?
the line do you guys see it do you guys see it the vision that's the vision happening yeah okay good one
we'll we'll cut it out this time before it dries and i can't see it anymore okay
okay oh wait this one is pretty good actually okay there we go okay Which way does it go?
Oh, this way.
Like so?
Wait, like...
Like...
Hmm?
Wait.
Flip it.
No, it didn't work that way either.
Wait, it was this way, wasn't it?
Wait.
How did I...
This is the way.
This is, because I see the marking on it.
Whatever!
Good enough, good enough, good enough, good enough.
Good enough.
Who cares?
Nobody cares.
I don't care.
Do you care?
Nobody, nobody cares.
Oops, sorry I punched my mic.
I punched my mic.
Ew.
Oh my gosh, it's basically the length I need it to be!
Wow!
Lucky duckie!
Okay, let me just trim a teeny tiny bit.
Wow, wow, wow, wow!
We'll do this side.
Ah!
Sorry.
Okay, we're fine, everything's fine.
Something tells me Mint is not an actual phantom.
Um, what are you talking about?
Uh, if you were, you know, here from earlier, you would know that I literally said I possessed a human today for this stream.
How does that not make me a real phantom?
In fact, I think that validates my case even more.
I think that makes me the most phantom because I possess this body that you're seeing.
But also, I mean, who knows?
Maybe in the future we can get a nice camera that like, like a ghost photography, you know?
But not photography, ghost video.
And you would be able to see me, maybe.
I've had that before in the past where like you know technology will get better but I've had it where you couldn't see me in the past where I was a little see-through but I decided because of this project I wanted to possess somebody to get it done you know hmm
let's glue glue, glue, glue glue, glue, glue, glue glue, glue, glue, glue, glue, glue okay that should be good enough We're in the question a friend mentioned.
Being acquainted with a former member of an idol group called Paspo!
Oh my gosh, whoa.
Paspo.
I haven't heard that group in a long time.
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
I had a friend that was very into Paspo.
I was never into them so much myself.
I have string everywhere.
If you still have cookies, maybe another could help you ignore the hot glue.
I think you're right.
Are you sure you don't want it?
Kojima is working on the ghost scanning tech.
Just a few more years.
The duel?
Oh god
I need just a little bit more blue I thought I had more
Where did I throw it?
Oh well okay I have the biggest the big piece oh wait maybe this is all I had left she wasn't a phantom how could she be sticking these pieces together with her hot ectoplasm gun yeah yeah exactly yeah totally yeah okay we need a teeny tiny piece sorry there's cat hair on it
do you guys think this should be donkey's real costume for actually this is her real costume for halloween actually i think donkey might wear this all the time
oh my god it does kind of look like len donkey is kitty girl len wait i see it i see it too because especially this looks like the the hair, the hair, ponytail.
Kagameenay, Kagameenaydoki.
What else can I add to this?
Oh, a color, that's right!
Hold on, let me go give him red.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Even better.
Oh, and also her blush, that's right, her blush.
Let's add the blush real quick.
put it i threw it over here and then it disappeared oh it fell on the ground hold on
so guys this is where dookitty on the full moon of halloween night she transforms she does lose her clothes in the process that's why well her under clothes that's why she only has her jacket on and um and yeah no wear doe kitty it's dokey dokey bird but as a wear kitty new lore yeah so if you don't want to get flashed you might want to skedaddle or something if you're not interested in that in that sight okay now but she's been domestic
She's been domesticated.
So she has a collar.
She's looking at me like, what are you doing?
Don't do this to me.
Don't kid you, this is for your best interest.
You are an indoor cat now.
You can't be an outdoor cat.
The world is scary out there.
With a leash.
Oh my gosh, wait.
She looks traumatized.
Wait, hold on.
This part is poking at me.
It's part of the pipe on her back.
I just gotta get my nails in there.
This should be better.
Oh, Bito.
Uh, Bito.
Can we go for...
A walk?
Yeah!
Can we go for a walk?
Please, yeah!
Q!
Y, why is only one of her eyes moving?
Yes.
Yay!
We completed one puppet!
How long did that take?
Only two hours!
Alright.
On to the next puppet.
Wait, who should I do though?
If I can only do two.
Nimi?
I did have Nimi on my list.
I bought her hair.
Look at this.
I got like the perfect color for her hair.
It's so perfect.
I was like, wow, this is Nimi Nightmare hair.
I got her dress but at the same time I wasn't quite sure
I wasn't quite sure about the costume you guys I have I can't even express to you how much felt I got okay hold on so you see these I'm just gonna keep piling it on I got really ambitious.
I got pretty ambitious.
I got really ambitious.
I thought, I could do this.
I don't even know what that was for, the brown.
I got really ambitious.
And then there's red over there too.
Because I thought about Berry Bud.
I was like, I'm gonna make everybody into a puppet, and then I underestimated how long one puppet would take.
Okay, let's do another one.
This one, I guess we'll still do this method where I just fold it in half.
It worked, I think.
It's okay because the felt was very inexpensive.
And I can always give it to somebody who does...
What's it called?
Crafting.
Hold on, I'm gonna throw away Doki's leftovers.
Are you gonna trace larger this time?
I don't have so much space, so I'm kind of like...
I'm kind of like...
Two part of the stream!
I have other Halloween things to do.
Hahaha.
Make finger puppets for the others.
Okay, let's see.
I did think about doing the sock puppets.
I was like, but I was like, if I'm making Halloween versions of them, like, if, you know, if I made this, you wouldn't really be able to tell, you know what I mean?
Like, if it were a sock puppet, you wouldn't be able to tell it was wearing.
kitty so get back over there get back over there oh don't get it where do kitty wants to go for a walk
i feel like i feel like you know those like shiba inu memes where you're just dragging the dog okay
okay but this one came out pretty well so i feel like i'm feeling confident in this one as well all right what i'm gonna do is the bottom is gonna be this entire thing.
But I just need to trace my hand now.
Wait.
Oh, it's so hard to stretch my hand!
Okay, okay, okay.
So, we'll start...
We'll do this.
Okay, be careful.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I'm not just tracing my hand.
I'm making a person.
Okay, hold on.
Trust the process?
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, all right.
I'm gonna know if I guess.
Look at...
Damn, girl.
Look at that...
Look at that body.
Woo!
She's posing for us.
Looks like she's the dancing queen.
This is definitely Nemi Nightmare.
I wish though I had some something to...
I wish I had something though to kind of pin it together.
Actually, hold on.
I'm not going to use these parts, so...
So when I'm cutting...
When I'm cutting it, it'll still stay together.
Just a little here too.
Okay.
I'm winding up the stream.
Get out of my fingers!
Stop being so obsessed with me!
Alright, let's do this.
Gingerbread Man.
The Halloween candy cane.
I'm the...
This, right?
Oh my gosh, it's so stinking cute!
I was like, I've never thought of a Halloween candy can.
Oopsie.
Oopsie!
Wait, I got some on my...
more on my hands I've never thought of a Halloween candy cane before though makes me kind of want one but I guess you have candy corn
am I okay it's just sharpie I'm totally fine
this is my thumb
alright I'm concentrated sorry guys the most adorkable person why would you call me a dork holding scissors you fool you fool okay big head big head big head big head round round size something sweet or bottom right yeah wait how did i cut that weird don't ask i was don't answer I mean,
rhetorical question.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's okay.
Calm down.
I'm calm.
You're calm?
We're calm.
Everything's calm.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're calm.
Calm.
Keep calm.
Okay.
flip it inside out and we'll make sure that i can fit in here wait that's that's my thought this feels so nimi nightmare okay what i had for nimi was a witch but oh we could do
zombie skelly uh naked
Uh, so...
If she's a zombie, though, I cut this out for no reason.
Because I have...
I have gray zombie skin.
I did think of Niminatar.
I did.
But I was like, how would I do that?
As the puppet.
I guess I could give it hooves here.
And then the nose.
But anything else would be like...
vampire Oh Wait, wait, wait Wait, I'm cooking, I'm cooking, I'm cooking, I'm cooking Um With Wait, wait, wait, remember how we were doing Doki's jacket and I was like, it looks like a vampire And then I have the red Wait, on the back Like so?
And then I can Line it with red And then we could do the black collar here.
And we could still do her dress.
Her green dress.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Vampire!
Vampire in Himmy Nightmare.
Evo, yura, yura, yura, yura, say...
They're pretty good.
Okay.
I'm making sure everything's lined up.
We'll make you happy!
I'll just send you guys the lyrics.
I'll just...
When I post the lyric video, I will post the lyrics in text form below as well for you all to gander at.
Sound good?
Good plan.
Because I'm gonna be performing it soon, so I want you guys to know the calls.
In fact, why didn't I perform at Club Iron Mouse yesterday?
I don't know.
Did you guys see me at Club Iron Mouse?
My voice felt so shaky.
I was like, hopefully I was okay.
I don't know.
For some reason, my voice was so, so shaky.
Probably because I was nervous.
And the subtitles were saying things like Snakey.
I was there for the concert.
The whole concert was absolutely awesome.
It was wise, wasn't it?
It really was so, so good.
Mousy worked her butt off for it.
I, you know.
I'm glad that me and Phoebe and Vicky could all sing together in some sort of capacity.
capacity you know in a live show since that was what we wanted to do you know how we wanted to be together okay and usually for live concerts it's very rare for me to sing a slower song i almost always go like do fast songs idle songs things that you could do a lot of Calls to...
Oh, there goes my glue stick.
But for this, I thought maybe...
A lot of people will sing faster songs, so I'll pick a slow song to give a bit of a...
A break for people.
Concert was peak.
Love to see any other guests in Mousy.
Yay!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Yeah, and people know Snake Eater, so I was like, maybe people will sing along.
It was fun, it was fun.
It was fun.
I love when people sing along.
Because also I do a lot of songs where it's like you do calls but you don't really sing along so much.
But for some songs I have coming up, I might spoil...
If you're going to US Idol Festival, I might spoil my set list so you guys can learn some of the calls.
Because two of them are songs I've never sung before.
And then one of, or I might switch out one, but then one song, I've only done karaoke once.
So, hmm.
Did I do this?
Okay.
Oh, no!
She ripped her pants!
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
It's a little scuffed, but it works.
It looks like a ghost.
How did I put my hand down when I...
I made this.
Excuse me?
Why is my thumbs?
Okay, whatever.
Wait, oh no, there's another hole, I think.
Oh there, okay.
Let's fix.
Wait, why?
Why is my thumb not reaching this time?
I messed up.
No.
You traced it around the other way.
This is supposed to be my tongue?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Repentor!
Thank
you!
Thank you!
Wait, play my song.
No.
Not the clown music.
Play my song.
Wait, oh there's...
Wait, wait, wait, I need the camera.
Wait, wait, wait, hold on!
I'm not ready!
Wait, where's the camera?
There it is, okay.
Oh!
My bad.
Okay, there we go.
Can I take your order?
Sikoshi freaky, but I shall try my own qi jishimasu I will kill you myself My boy, my kid Docky, docky, docky, docky Docky, docky, docky
Wait, I have to pull up Nimi Nightmare.
Did I...
I don't think I...
Oh, yes I did.
I was like, I don't think I downloaded her reference sheet, but I did.
I was ahead of the game.
You're pretty good.
Thanks.
And we can use the brown.
For her ears.
Good enough.
So we're making...
We're making...
Nimi Nightmare.
Vampire.
You could stab me, but don't stab yourself.
Don't worry, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Thank you, Dove.
Okay.
Uh, let's see.
Yeah, my hands are huge.
Thank you for noticing.
Oh, okay, let's get a couple things.
Because what I'm gonna do first is I'm gonna make her nurse...
Nurse... head.
That should be a good size.
Big hand equals a lot to hold.
I can hold so many things.
Yeah, I have big hands, which means I'm...
Which means I'm huge, so you don't want to mess with me.
I'd be like, what?
She's like, twice the size we thought she was.
Has anyone told you lately that your work is really and truly important?
It's not...
It is!
Is it?
I guess for those who watch streams to go to sleep, VTubers provide lots of content for that.
It's me.
I'm one of those people that watches streams to sleep.
Oh, you can see it already.
It already looks like her.
Okay.
I'm going to make her ears.
What I'm doing is I'm making these first.
And then we'll put her hair on top.
Yes, yes, yes.
Ears time!
I've never made a tape of your ear.
Yeah.
Does she have a tail?
She doesn't have a tail.
A tape ear.
Not a tape worm.
I hope not.
You've gotten me through some hard days.
It is important work.
Really?
I don't know.
I'm glad.
I mean, what is it?
What did they say?
They say, protect the arts.
My, this is my craft.
My mining and my craft.
Protect the arts!
I can't see it!
I can't see!
Wait, it's not supposed to be pointy even a little bit.
It's supposed to be the most round.
Round, round, round, round round.
I wanted to make myself today, but I don't know if I will.
Actually, I wanted, I was gonna make myself naked because I didn't buy any supplies from me.
So I was going to be naked.
And I don't want to hear any objections.
Be like, no, God, the scariest costume you could be.
That is a pretty spooky costume.
Probably.
Are you guys seeing it?
I'm like mega seeing it right now.
I'm like super, this is...
Like, this is Nimi Nightmare.
100%.
But her ears go in front, I think.
Okay, now I glue.
I glue.
So you were going to make yourself in the swimsuit you were going to ask for from Ayami earlier.
No, no, that's why I don't want her to make me naked because that's stealing my Halloween costume.
Uh, one of us would have to get dressed.
And this ain't, it ain't gonna be me.
Did you guys watch Ayami Mama's 3D debut?
It seemed a little scuffed.
Poor girl.
Poor Mama.
Mama.
Poor thing.
It's a little scuffed.
But it was very cute.
Her new...
I want to say Fuku.
I want to say Fuku, but at the same time, I'm like...
I already know what I'm doing for my next outfit.
And I don't... And it will be around some...
So, unless I, like...
You bought all the fabrics if she didn't have a choice.
It'll be around summer, so it's really kind of like...
I have to prioritize what I want because of Celia's schedule, you know?
Hmm.
You're very inspiring, Minto.
I started drawing this year because I wanted to get good enough.
What did I draw?
I've ever... Oh my god!
Thank you!
I have to think really hard about what outfits I want because it's like I get fewer, you know what I mean?
They have to be like, what do I really, really want?
Hold on, what did I do with your hair, Nimi?
Oh, here it is.
Unless I don't work with Celia, but you know.
You make a bad day better, a good day better.
Why was the charge of water treatment plant?
The water would taste extra nice.
Hmm?
I don't get it.
Better, better.
Betty bought some...
Betty bought some butter, butter.
But it made her better butter.
Did the better...
Did the...
Betty stream make her day better?
Better batter.
I thought when I saw the silhouette of your comfy outfit, I thought you were getting a gal giaruminto.
That would be crazy for a second outfit.
Oh, okay, her hair.
It has like a...
Hold on, Nimmy.
Go there.
It has like a craziness going on.
Where's my...
Ah, Sharpie!
Okay.
Nimmy's hair...
might be the more difficult.
But we're gonna we're gonna attempt.
I can't grab this.
Is this a string?
Yeah.
How do I get sharp?
I saw some of you guys saying how to get Sharpie off of your hands.
How do you?
Mortals!
Humans!
Tell me now!
Tell me how to erase this so that when I remove my soul from this person's body, they never even know that I've was here rubbing alcohol wait so i okay i take the alcohol and i rub it
rubbing alcohol isopropyl alcohol okay i will try thank you thank you thank you okay mouthwash people are going crazy over the mouth wash mouth washing Nendroid.
Minto of the hand.
What is the Minto word of the day?
Waffle.
Nail polish remover.
Oh no!
But I will remove the nail polish.
Thank you for the fun times already.
Thank you!
Okay.
How to...
Nimi is kind of intimidating.
to me so i'm gonna do my best all right once again we start with her her her her vents she has vents as well so we'll do the framing and then i'll do the back like i did with doki and then i'll do the side pun that's what we'll do that was what we'll do yes yes yes Yes,
yes, yes.
Oh gosh, I already made it too thin, I think.
Oh wait, and also, oh my gosh, I forgot to do the eyeball check.
Yay!
Okay, good, good, good, good, good.
Let me see.
You can see, like, yeah, it's pretty...
Unless I make it thinner, I mean, we could do that.
Let me try.
Even she's looking, she's looking.
it's really just that her hair is like like this it's kind of difficult but I'll do my best don't kill me naplings I'm already done
this one is so much easier to draw on okay
okay I thought I spilled something okay
I look alive today but I oh my gosh wait wait wait wait because I'm possessing someone, can you guys say look alive?
Can you guys I've always wanted to be told that.
Like, you know how in the movies, or like before work or something, they're like, alright everybody, look alive!
Look alive!
Okay, please.
Okay.
How do I do that?
Wait, no!
Wait, how do I look alive?
Hold on.
Look alive, me too!
Do something!
Jazz hands!
That's me screaming at the existential dread.
I'm going to die someday.
It could be any day.
It could be tomorrow.
But it's not right now.
Yay.
Look alive, Minto, you got work to do.
Yeah, oh, I do.
I do.
Okay, we're cutting out the pieces.
I might have made this one a little too detailed, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Look alive, Miss Maid.
Yeah.
As a ghost, aren't you already dead?
Yeah, but if I'm possessing somebody who is alive currently, then I get to pretend.
role playing as a living person today.
Thank you so much for the podcast, thank you guys for the Super Chat too.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Stop reminding me of my mortality.
Oh, my bad.
Don't worry about it.
Don't think about it.
Don't don't don't that it.
Just think about Vampire Nimi Nightmare, which we are constructing at this very moment.
Ah!
I've never seen anyone move their hands as much?
No.
This is, I think, quite normal for a lot of streamers.
Especially, like, when I... Because...
How do I say?
I don't often get to show hands.
So.
Bing bong.
Oh, there we go.
Oh gosh.
Please.
This one is really soft compared to where Do-Kitty's hair.
Like you can- like so floppy, you know.
Where Do-Kitty's hair was so hard.
Even though- same brand.
I got these all the same place.
She's got hands.
Catch these hands.
Catching my hands.
Hold my hands.
Don't do that.
It's embarrassing.
This, like, felt it also feels so nice.
It's so soft.
Probably would have been really great as chest hair.
For a furry.
Wait, the niminitar.
We could still do it.
Alright, moment of truth, everybody.
Moment of truth.
It's a little off, but it works.
It
works.
It works.
Like, here she's, she's, you can't really see.
Hold on, if I move it over a smidge.
balled on each side that's okay that's fine glue lock her in place lock her in place oh gosh oh oh she might have she might have bled out a little bit but I'm surgeon looks just like me yeah she's bleeding out code code nine i don't know is there gonna be puppet of snake your best friend how how delusional do you think i am galbanana
My drink today is a ginger honey tea, but the ginger is so spicy.
It's very strong.
Oh, wait.
Before we do that, I'm going to do the cross on her,
even though it's not green.
But it's not red, so it's fine.
We won't get flagged by the...
By the...
What are they called?
I don't remember.
this super cute puppet thank you thank you for possessing someone with such cute hands and nails wow you think so i think they're not so great which is why i never want to show maybe one day i could possess someone with like a hand model you know what was i thinking why didn't i possess a hand model i'm so dumb i feel like when i'm putting on their hair like i'm Billy doing like a hair transplant.
Where do people go?
Where, what's that country that everybody goes to to get their hair transplant?
Turkey!
Wait.
Look, look, look.
Was that a setup just to do that?
No, I couldn't remember the name of the country.
Oh wait, I should have moved the bald spot to this side because then I could hide it with her ponytail.
Well, she's a vampire.
She could be flipped.
It's opposite day.
It's opposite day!
Add more hair?
Oh, we really are turkey.
Gobble, gobble.
Happy Thanksgiving.
I mean, it's gonna be in November before we know it.
But didn't Canadian Thanksgiving just happen?
I do have to do the back of her hair, but...
Nimmy's a vampire.
She is for my Halloween puppet series.
Wait, it's so cute!
I want to try and do the little flippy of her hair.
Okay, there's gonna be an attempt here.
All right, we're doing brave science.
Pray for me!
Oh, Bogos!
I might be too good at this.
I really should take commissions.
Maybe I'll do like a very limited, like a merch drop one day where I take like five people and you can get a custom puppet made by me.
It would be much more detailed than this too because I would put much more care into it.
She's really been showing off her booty.
My booty!
I would love to do like kind of hand mids.
stuff like that, you know?
Obviously, I could only do so much of them, so many of them.
You could make a few in auction, though.
I don't know, though.
I feel worried about an auction.
I don't want people being like, I must...
It's a one-of-a-kind Mickey Original.
I must pay the money.
I don't want to cause anything like that.
Oh, maybe if it's for a fundraiser, though.
That's true.
That would be good.
It's for like a charity.
Charity.
Well, I guess the charity is not the one getting the puppet.
Because can you imagine?
I'm like, this is for the children.
They'll be like, um, thank you.
This is for the children to play with.
Nimi,
let's dance together.
Wait.
Oh my god, she's so talented.
Okay, sorry.
Sorry about that.
Intermission.
Okay.
We have...
All right.
I don't need anything.
anything handmade, all I need is your hand!
You're trying to jump off the hand!
This isn't even my body!
Wait, what if it's like, it, what's it called?
Like, wait, hold on.
Oh, it looks like, it looks like, it looks like the hand from Adam's family.
Thing, thing, thing, thing, thing, thing.
Who is cousin it?
Who's cousin, what does he do?
This is the bald guy, right?
No, that's not the bald...
Oh, it's...
Oh, the hairy guy!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, that's Uncle Fester.
Yeah.
Fester is the bald guy.
I always forget that.
There's a hairy guy in there.
Okay, next, um...
I kind of want to do her smile.
Is that okay?
Okay.
I kind of want to make her have like little mischievous eyebrows to be like.
Wait, but I might have to cut her hair a bit more.
Hold on.
I got to get nice and close.
Let me.
It didn't really work.
But that's okay.
Did you make the puppets twerk?
Sorry about that.
Okay, anyway.
Um...
Oh, her smile- Oh, I want to give her mischievous eyebrows.
Okay, hold on.
That's good enough.
The other one, it- And then, and then, we'll give her a mouth.
Is this adjacent to making your friends in the Sims?
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Points for that puppet action.
So cute.
Okay, so before we make her vampire cape, we're going to make her dress.
So let me grab the green and the white.
Green, white.
Okay.
No pressure.
Oh, she looks all tucked in.
So cute.
Oh.
Impressive.
Very nice.
Thank you.
A little bow.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Speaking of the Adams family, I got to be lurch in a production of the musical.
Since I'm a little short for lurch, I got to wear stilts from 5 foot 7 to over 7 foot tall.
That's crazy.
Whoa.
She looks so silly.
Okay, so about here.
I'm getting ink all over my fingers again.
I just gotta trace her body.
I gotta trace her hot bod.
That's all I gotta do.
You could always put the green behind the white to cut it.
What do you mean?
You're...
It's my birthday tomorrow!
And I mark Tyson's ass!
Happy birthday!
Oh, to trace her body!
Oh, I get it, I get it.
That's okay though, I'm already here.
I'm already here.
The side was not as thick.
Oh yeah.
Oh, be careful.
We'll go like this.
I need to decide where I want her...
Her shirt to go up to, you know?
Her dress I'm in.
Like that.
Oh, wow.
Have you been working out in me?
She's naked!
All right.
Oh, wait.
I need to make it a little thicker.
So it covers her completely.
YouTube's gonna ban me.
You think I should give this to her?
You think she'll want it?
You think she'd want this?
Nemi, I made you.
This seems like something a stalker would give somebody.
Too hot for you too.
And can you use your powers to make my food taste better?
Of course!
Moe Moe Kim!
Wait, it was kind of perfect.
Don, thank you so much for the food!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um, okay.
There you go.
It should be so yummy now.
It should be the most delicious.
Pika pika boo!
Pika pika pika pika boo.
You're pretty good.
Alright!
Okay!
Wait, that actually works so well!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, now mid-out-made apron.
Hmm.
How do I want to do this?
Let me glue this first.
Oops, I'm getting it on...
I'm getting it on my glue gun.
Can I get a hat?
A head pat for Nimi.
Like that?
One second though, free!
Free!
Okay.
Ah!
She's looking at me.
Why are you looking at me like that?
Hmm?
Nimi Nima?
She looks mischievous.
She's up to no good.
Oh.
I don't think it'll fall over, but I just don't want it shaking so much.
So you guys don't get, like, sick.
Motion sick.
Cute Minto hand gestures and clapping is cute.
Hand heart is my weakness.
Good work on the craft.
Thank you.
Tech-tech-tech-y.
Okay.
Now...
Apron.
How do I want to do this?
How, how, how?
Probably.
What do we do?
Is I...
Like so.
I just got myself again.
Like this.
Okay.
Booby time.
Where's her?
Okay, this is her waist right here.
Oh wait, booby.
Oopsie.
I think you wiggle waggle never gets old, which is why you're still 19.
Yes, sir.
Okay, booby.
But I already messed up.
Oh, man.
I can't use the back because it'll be aligned to this side, you know?
Maybe I can just use a different part.
We'll just redo it.
We'll redo, redo, redo, redo, redo.
redo
okay that should be okay that should be okay
here waste
boob wait yes yes i think yes i think oops oh no it's a little crooked it's fine it's fine It's fine!
We're doing it live!
It's fine!
Add another layer of white for volume of boobs!
That is such a funny way of having to censor it.
Hopefully this works.
Hopefully this works, okay.
Let's go away.
Alright.
B-B-B-B-B-B-Bee-Boo B-Boo!
Back to the Nyanya version.
I kind of want to put, like, blood on it, you know?
Is this going to work?
Actually, I have no idea.
I might have totally messed this up, but that's fine.
I have a lot of white.
I have a lot of white felt, so it's okay.
This one is also so flimsy.
I feel like I measured it correctly, though.
Besides the bottom.
Let's see.
Wait.
Nimmy would approve.
You think so?
Her boobs are also a little misshapen.
Wait, this kind of works.
This kind of works, right?
You think it works?
And then maybe I could put a strap.
Like that.
Hold on.
Like all the way around.
I think it'll work.
I have nothing long enough verse.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Good stuff, good stuff.
It's a little crooked, but who cares?
Who cares?
It's part of the art.
It's part of the art history.
Wait, uh...
This one I was able to flip around because I did it incorrectly to begin with, so...
They ended up working out.
Okay.
I have to be very, very careful.
Very, very careful here.
Oh!
Oh, please, go down a little.
Um, okay, good enough.
Safe!
We're safe!
Ooh!
Okay.
And what are... Oh, here.
Alright.
let's uh let's
cut the bottom well i actually i need to cut both sides but oh wait yeah this is the bottom
very very careful and
then a little off the top a little off the top a little
yippee oh that looks so good
I don't think we need the glue.
I'll just make it nice and taut.
There we go.
Oh, I wonder if I can make some ruffles.
Hmm.
It might be difficult, though.
It's fine.
Well, no, it's fine.
You can still tell.
It kind of looks more like what's it called?
like a chibi nimi and
now we vampire it we make it a little bit more spooky vampiry let's see how do I want to do this um
traveling in a few hours I'm super nervous but my ocean is cute fills me with determination also cute nails thank you thank you thank you have a good trip Salkin tell your girlfriend I said hi I mean I Girlfriend.
Taylor, I said hi.
Or wait, are you going home?
I can't remember.
Blood on the apron.
I think I have an idea.
Hold on.
One moment.
Our girlfriend.
I think he's going out to visit.
Okay, that's what I thought.
Pompoms of blood.
Pom poms of blood!
Wait, actually?
This is so...
Wait, I could do the pink on her cheeks.
I have to find more though.
I'm dropping all of them.
Okay, I found some pink.
Visiting her for a week.
Ah, okay, okay.
Ah, have fun!
okay now we add the blood cover her in oranges it's it looks more orange on this on the camera but I promise you it's red
I'm just dumping all of these out at this rate like that like that
kind of like sporadic it's fuzzy blood.
I don't know what else to use.
I guess I could use what I did for Doki's collar, but...
Looks like pepperoni.
Why do you want me to...
You want... I have a...
Alright, guys.
It's guro time.
This is where the real spooky stream starts.
It's not my body, so... Why should I care?
and just possess anybody I want.
Maybe I... Hold on.
Let's see how we can use these, though.
Maybe I can, like, cut off the fuzz or something.
If I push them down, if I make them real flat...
Uh...
If I make them real flat...
Maybe.
Or...
Tear it apart.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, that actually looks so good!
Movie magic.
I don't think it'll stay though.
I don't know how to glue this on here.
Nemi pepperoni pizza.
I came here for Crafts did for Witchcraft.
How do I glue this on, though?
Well, at first, I mean, glue these.
It's hard because, you know, with what's it called?
With the hot glue, it's like so...
I was going to say, it's so sticky.
I mean, it's glue, but it has, like, you know, the stringiness to it, too, which makes it more difficult.
Hmm.
Let's see.
Yeah, it does harden fast too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to sacrifice.
I'm going to sacrifice myself.
Well, wait.
It's...
Wait.
No, Ron.
What is it?
Use a pipe cleaner to press it down.
and rip it away.
Oh, maybe.
Wait, though.
Only a little, it only sheds a little bit.
It only sheds a little bit.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this one might be a little bit tougher.
Okay, we lost some in the process, but that's okay.
That's okay.
It's only... There we go.
There we go.
Nice!
And we'll put some, we'll put some, like, down here too.
This one's a pretty big stand.
We can, uh, separate you.
Put some down there.
Nice and bloody.
Nice and bloody!
Mmm, kawaii.
Kawaii?
Kawaii, kawaii, kawaii kawaii.
Kawaii, I think.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, I just called myself a genius, and now, oh, no, everything's gone bad.
Uh-oh, the glue gun has gone rogue, everybody.
Oh, go, ow, ah!
It's fine, it looks more natural this way, right?
It looks more natural.
Oh, gosh, she's really shedding now.
Oh, gosh, okay.
We're fine.
There we go!
Yeah!
How many hand puppets have you made?
Oh, um...
Two!
Oh!
Pick number three, my lord.
Three!
I made three.
Pick number three, my lord.
To-toi!
Nah.
As in, this is number two.
Okay.
One more to glue.
One more blood.
And then we can make her vampire cape.
Honestly, I don't even...
Does she need the cape at this point?
She looks so good as is.
She looks so...
No, I want her to have a bit of a costume.
Doki had fur, so Nimi gets her cape.
You know?
That's how it works.
Okay.
This is neat for Nimmi and 2.
Her neck needs reinforcement.
What are you talking about?
Reinforcement.
Piece to piece.
Sanchez!
Thank you so much for the hugger so much.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I can't get over how good the blood ended up looking.
Wow.
Good job team!
Good job!
Okay.
Lastly, is her cape.
All right, hold on.
I can close out of some of this stuff.
Oh, here we go.
because she's a vampire she needs a vampire cape why did I put the other oh here the pom-poms her cake no not her cake vampires can't have cake too much garlic okay um what was I doing oh I remember
Oh, I can't tell.
I was trying to see how long I've been streaming for.
That's all.
I guess I could have just asked you guys.
Like, YouTube changed the back-end layout, so I can't tell anything anymore.
Like, where anything is or what?
Like, I was like, where's the stream time?
Or, oh, I'm lost!
I'm lost!
Okay, 15 minutes.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, cape.
We need black and we need red.
Let me go get the red real quick.
No,
because I want to be fancy and I want to line the black.
Uh, I want to line it like it's a true vampire cape, you know?
Okay.
Uh, I know I had a smaller piece of the black felt.
Where did it?
Oh, here it is.
I know, so fancy, so fancy.
This should be just enough.
Oh!
There's red fuzz everywhere.
And then I'll do...
She will have neck reinforcement.
It will be from the cape.
And then I'll line the cape so that the back is black, but the inside is red like so.
And then when you turn her around, it'll be black.
Oh, I forgot to do the back of her hair.
Um...
Let me do that real quick.
I at least did that for Doki.
Can we get a Mike's to class at all?
It'll be like, all right, I'm Mike's to class at all.
Bald Nimi, bald Nimi.
I mean, just trace the outline of her head.
I should have done that.
Why didn't I do this with Doki?
Okay.
Oh, I already closed out of her reference.
Hold on.
Okay.
It's really just like...
I don't want to make it too difficult for myself.
Okie dokie Let's Except I already finished dokie We're on Nime.
Let's cut
We were trusting the process We really I think it's because the first one Was the front The bangs were so stinking good That like I was like I have an eye for this I'm a genius And so I just trusted it And you know It mostly worked I have a feeling Mike would only Agreed to a puppet if his puppet got a beer.
I agree.
I mean, it has to have a beer.
It's like part of his appeal.
Did you see me just twirl this around?
Like, you know when dogs are trying to get comfortable?
I'm like, hmm.
Trying to find the sweet spot.
That's me.
Gotta finesse it first.
Right, right.
I gotta feel what...
I gotta feel it out.
Know what feels right in my hand.
Are you guys feeling spooky?
Are you guys feeling the Halloween spirit?
Lots of people have been doing Halloween stuff, so...
I love when people do seasonal things.
It's so fun.
What's great about Halloween, too, is because...
I mean, I like to do the crafts, the Halloween crafts, but...
You also get, like, spooky games and everything, and...
Yeah, you're getting there!
You know what would really get you there?
A pumpkin.
You gotta get yourself a pumpkin.
That makes everything feel...
Like, fall and Halloween.
That's, like, the key.
As soon as you stop getting pumpkins, it doesn't feel like Halloween anymore.
You gotta get yourself a pumpkin.
Horror Nights last week.
How was it?
Oh my gosh.
I've had a pumpkin on my desk for a month.
So true.
Yeah!
Mimi, one day I'll make you a puppet.
And then when I see you again, I'll give it to you.
But maybe you're already a witch, so it wouldn't be a Halloween one, maybe.
Maybe just a regular one.
Oh, shut up.
Speaking of Halloween, when's the Over the Garden Wall Watch Along?
It is!
Hold on, let me check my account.
The 26th.
It's a Sunday.
Sunday, the 26th, is when I'll do a member's Watch Along of Over the Garden Wall.
Wow!
Wait!
I just realized how much of genius i am and you can see the little hair flippy wait actually i'm gonna flip it around so that it's clean this is so good oh ah thank you guys for the gift thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
doki was truly like our test subject and Nimmy is our perfect child it's just how it goes you don't know what you're doing with the first one and then you have another kid you still don't know what you're doing
randomish question did you ever play franbow I haven't played franbow only a little misfortune but there's a game coming out that has franbow and little misfortune in it I should play it so I can play the new game.
Mimi's turning out amazing.
I know, I'm shocked.
There's a little bit of her head up top with some glue.
But it's fine, you can't tell.
And
what happened with you?
Actually, I know, I still think Doki looks pretty cute, though.
Okay, well, we're not done yet.
We're not done yet.
Why was I putting on her hair?
Oh, I guess for the cape.
Don't scare us that Naruto.
No!
But in my first attempt.
Oh my gosh.
I am.
Thank you so much for the music.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Doki Doki.
Uh...
We trace her body.
Doki, that's it by yo!
Oh no!
Actually,
since it's a cape, I just need to get like And I don't need to do the arms.
You know?
We just need to do the outline of it.
Outline of her.
The shape of Nimi Nightmare.
Maybe I shouldn't have done this though with...
Okay, hold on.
Like so.
Yeah, yeah, this looks good.
That looks fine.
It's just a cape.
Okay.
Cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut.
That there.
It's just a cape.
I could have made it...
Actually, I can make it a little wider.
We can make it a little my wider so it sticks out more.
Like that.
And
then...
Oh, maybe we should have made it a little bit longer, too, but that's okay.
That's okay, that's okay.
Ooh!
Woo!
You can't scare me.
I'm a ghost.
Oh, it's me.
Nimmy the vampire.
Okay, hold on.
Let me do the red lining now.
Everyone, every good...
Whoops.
Every good vampire.
Where cape means red.
Woof.
Woof, woof, woof, woof.
I'm a dog.
Go begone, begone.
Red like blood.
I was at Club Iron Mouse last night and it was so hyped to see it perform the best song ever.
Yeah!
Oh, and Nimi turned out so well.
Thank you!
And Doki too, right?
right and Doki too right yes we don't talk about Doki no we don't talk about Doki bird we don't talk about Doki no no no okay all right all right
All right!
What is a ghost favorite kind of pie?
Boo-berry!
Um...
Actually, it's...
This is so awkward.
Oh my gosh, actually...
I like apple pie.
The most.
I don't know how to tell you.
I mean, I just did.
I did just tell you.
Do we share a brain cell?
Whenever I'm about to make a reference, you do it first.
You are becoming Minto.
Every time I possess you, every time I possess you, I just... This is your brain.
I leave a little bit of traces.
Wait, this is your brain.
Sprinkled in there.
You know?
Happens to me too.
Yeah, I'm possessing you too, but I sprinkle it in there.
I thought I was going to use way more glue.
But I also thought I was going to be making, like, way more puppets.
So, I thought I got so much glue.
That's okay.
Better to have more than not enough.
No, I...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, brain sprinkles.
Tax, keep up the good work.
How does the glue taste?
You try it.
Try it.
How's it taste?
Yummy?
My tongue hurts.
Yeah, you should have waited for it to cool.
Like I told you.
Next time you listen to Minto, I have some good advice.
Will I fail my drug test?
if Minto is in my brain.
No, no, no, that's ridiculousness.
All right, let's trim a tad where I messed up.
And we could do up here.
Perfect.
And our cape is complete.
Nimi, where'd you go?
Where are you?
Wait, where did I put Nimi?
I want
it under her hair, like so.
Like this.
Okay.
And then we'll do her, the, the, this part.
Look how good that is.
It's too good.
Too good.
Very, very carefully.
That's me.
I'm- I can make all your plushy hand- or not plushy.
All your- all your hand puppet me-hits.
The kowtinyin minotaur is next, right?
Okay, now... Oops.
I got glue all over the- the- these other scraps I was gonna use.
My bad.
That's fine.
I have plenty of black.
Oh, here.
I have some more here too.
Actually, I think I was saving this for you.
the caller perfect okay how do i want to do this for a first try for a first try on your first puppet nimi turned out amazing
well oh watch this that thank you oh my gosh i that's what i've been putting it trying to put it on the plate this whole time it's fine it's okay it's okay um
first try
First try.
Well, how could I make her look more like Doki?
Like Doki?
Is it because of the ears?
Needs more smug.
Doki looks fantastic.
You think so?
And maybe, like, if you say smug, I could do, like, an upturned mouth.
I could do an upturned mouth and then, like, the eyebrows.
With different shade of blonde.
We're working with felt here.
You got it.
Oh, maybe, like, redo the whole thing.
She's so distressed.
I mean, she's a wear kitty.
Alright, okay.
We'll make her...
Like that?
How do I have so much felt on this?
Oh, my poor fingers.
You can't even see that she has whiskers because of the collar.
Can you do her gloves?
Wait, let me go back to my Doki reference.
I downloaded everybody.
and I've only got two done, man.
Oh, we're a fang.
Yeah, I could do that.
I could do that.
Give her a fang and make her mouth open because her mouth is always open for some reason.
Okay.
Oh, I made it kind of big.
Guys, look what up.
This is.
Look at my fingers.
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe?
Looking good?
Don't say d'Ate bayou!
I wonder if I could do her gloves.
I'm trying to think of what else I...
Maybe I could do like the...
I could do like her belts and stuff across her too.
Hold on.
I have the brown.
Let me do... let me do her belts.
That should be enough, right?
Probably?
Oh, wait, okay, wait, I need two, I need one more.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's looking better already, I think.
Wait.
He's the good one.
Uh-oh, wait.
I messed up, I think.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Okay, just enough.
Just enough.
Perfect.
Okay, glue.
It's not Naruto.
You guys are gonna make me cry.
At least this was my first attempt.
If it were like, if I was, what if I came in being like, guys, I'm a professional puppet maker.
I've made thousands of puppets in my afterlife time.
Oops, I did it the wrong way, but that's okay.
Sneak that out.
Yay!
Okay!
It's looking a bit better?
Right, right!
It's looking a bit better, right!
Outline the ears more.
Yeah, I'll try.
I'll try.
How can I do that though?
Hmm.
Maybe if I...
Wait, hold on, let me try something.
Let me try this.
What if I give her like some white tuft?
You know?
Like this.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, like that.
I'll fix it, but...
Okay, okay.
Hold on, Nimmy.
I need you to move, please.
Wait.
Nimmy was so close to perfection.
We're so close to finishing her.
But Doki needs emergency surgery.
Don't kiddie needs emergency surgery!
It's not Boruto.
I'll bet this person's life on it, whoever I'm possessing.
She's coming back!
We're not losing her!
I can fix her!
A little bit more.
Oops.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah, there we go, there we go.
Dr. Freakin' Stein!
She is alive!
Get the side drip!
Oops, sorry.
I mean, her expression, she really looks like she's losing, like she's dying, though.
Her expression alone makes me look like, makes me feel like we're losing her.
How about that?
That looks better, I think.
What else can I add?
I like how I included her undershirt.
But I did not click.
I gave her the hair.
Guys, I don't know what to tell you.
I think it's just Doki Bird looks like Naruto.
It's not me.
It's her.
Like, you can blame Doki Bird's design.
I think she just looks like Naruto.
Don't blame me.
Blame Doki.
her to her exact likeness wow blue thank you for the spooky spooky number thank you i think your doki puppet looks great me and don't thank you it looks just like her exactly okay
well that's dokitty we're dokitty and now we finish vampire nimi we get locked back in everybody we're locked We just have, we just have, probably I'll do like this.
Okay, I think I know how I'm gonna do this.
Doesn't have to be very tall.
Oh gosh, okay.
Maybe like here.
There.
If I mess up, if I mess up, it's fine.
Nibbi!
Oh my gosh, down blinks!
Look!
I made you into a vampire!
You go from one nimi to the next.
Except this one's a vampire!
For Halloween!
That's her Halloween costume.
Wait, I can't...
I can't see.
Why did it get... Oh, I was like, why is it getting so dark in my room?
It's because I have like dimming lights.
Means it's time for me to shut down soon.
I was like, I can't see though, I can't see.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Whoa.
Hello.
I possessed some.
You're probably like, oh my gosh.
Minto is not a ghost.
No, no.
I possessed someone today.
So I'm in somebody's body and I'm making puppets of my friend.
I made do kitty.
This is not Boruto.
This is wear do kitty for Halloween.
Her Halloween costume is a wear, wear kitty.
is doki doki bird as a wear kitty and then and then uh and then nimi is a vampire obviously so and i'm finishing her up i'm actually just putting on the collar right now i'm measuring it out let's see bleh bleh okay that should be fine maybe Hmm...
Okay.
Thank you so much for all the...
Gifted!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Wait!
Okay.
And then...
It
might be a little short, but it's fine probably.
Blah!
She's here to soak your blood!
And eat your nightmare!
Actually, I'm going to cut it a little bit.
So, wait, actually, no, it's fine the way it is.
She's here to suck your blood and enter nightmares.
Blah, blah.
I can bring it down just a tad, probably.
Give her a little bit more neck, maybe.
Yes, yes, yes.
Happy Halloween.
Like so?
They don't need more neck.
It's my art style.
Are you judging my art style?
Are you saying I need to go back to art school?
My degree is useless?
I love no-neck women.
That's why it's my art style.
Can we eat the extra glue sticks?
Oh, I just ran out.
You know, I also got this to try it.
I got this pen to try.
Wait, I want to use it.
I wanted to try and make my own hair.
Let's try it.
How it would look.
Wait, it would look so good!
Wait.
Oh my god.
Maybe I do need to do another stream then.
Maybe.
It doesn't show up very well on the camera, but...
Whoa!
I picked the perfect color!
Tombow.
Well, guys.
Uh, hold one moment.
I'm cleaning up.
I made two friends today.
I made two friends.
We made Nibbi as a vampire for Halloween.
And we made Doki Bird as a...
As a...
Wear Kitty.
No, it's not Naruto.
So...
Those are their Halloween costumes.
Decided by me.
I think you discovered a hidden talent today, Minky.
These came out so good.
You think so?
I'm really proud of the Nimeo one.
I'm not gonna lie.
We need more arts and crafts, dreams.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Do the eyes shake?
They do.
Ooh, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, the awesome stream.
Thank you so much.
you in honor of snakey you're so so pretty or was it supreme oh supreme but but up thank you guys i had so much fun maybe i really did discover a hidden talent i can make only naruto though you're proud of nimi only i'm i'm proud of both of them but i think nimi's looks so good
I'll try and do like a video or something later $5 Naruto versus the $5,000 Dimmy Hopefully Nimmy is gone I will see if I could give this to her If she wants it I don't want her to be like I'm taking your garbage But like even the back Like I think I think it almost is like a professional level.
What?
Nya, nya, nya.
Oh my, she's choking.
Is
it good?
Oh, wait.
Oh, come here.
It's a choking bird.
It's choking bird.
Here's for the Naruto.
Anyways, bye-bye.
See you guys later.
Bye-bye.
caramel dancing.
Oh no, I'm making them kiss.
I can't.
My thumb doesn't reach up here.
Okay.
Bye-bye!
Oh my god!
I have thank you!
Now I will thank you!
What the heck?
Why?
After I finished!
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much!